Chris Gore, Founder/Owner of
FilmThreat/Author/Filmmaker: Please, if you're
a studio executive and you are watching this,
everything is so corporate. It's like what did
Francis Ford Coppola say? Factory filmmaking. Just
take the drivers from Fast and the Furious and put
them in the Transformers cars. I miss loving Star
Wars. I miss loving it! I used to love it. Yes,
I saw Wonder Woman 1984. I want to know what's
going to happen next and I can't tell you how
many times I've seen the first five or 10 minutes
of a movie and I don't want to watch the rest of
it or if I could just do the snap that Thanos
did I would get rid of every franchise reboot
post probably '92. You know where's the
movie that we all love without debate,
that we've all loved...please Hollywood,
realize that it's not going to work.
Film Courage: Would you say that 99
percent of all movies today are garbage?
Chris Gore:
In an age where most movies are referred to as
content I would say that 99 percent of most movies
are pretty are pretty bad. I always try to like
when when I say 99 percent I mean of mainstream it
really is when you look at and especially I think
one of the best examples of this is the sort of
Zack Schneider's Justice League and how that was
you know bungled the the that how that was bungled
how the Star Wars franchise was bungled how they
could not I mean to me I I'm the studio executive
in charge of Star Wars and we're making a new
Star Wars movie and the first thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to put han luke and leia in a
scene together and the fact that that moment we
will never be able to have that moment in cinema
when Carrie Fisher was alive that to me is I mean
that's that's malpractice that's studio
malpractice the fact that they had with
Zack Snyder's vision what he was building up to
be I think seeing the four-hour final product of
what Zack Snyder's Justice League turned out to be
and that they made this garbage thing Joss Whedon
I mean it's disheartening to me to see that I will
say on an indie level I tend to take like a glass
half full view and I tend to always look for
the positive when it comes to indie films
because you cannot compare the the the you can't
compare an indie movie shot in 12 days for 10 000
to Justice League whichever version you're talking
about you can't compare because in my mind there
is no excuse for a studio to fail when they put
out a blockbuster movie you have no excuse your
job is to entertain me not lecture me not lecture
me your job is to entertain me unfortunately we
live in a time you know back in the day when Star
Wars was first made I feel like they were checking
one box it was called fun and now there's not only
there's a million boxes that must be checked there
are all sorts of noting and committees and
this thing and this is where you end up with
you know that last Star Wars movie by J.J.
Abrams is unwatchable I mean it's it's it's
garbage it's it's it's exactly it informs exactly
everything wrong with the studio system it's it's
terrible so I look at like the the the Justice
League debacle the the the Star Wars franchise
and how that has been was mishandled and I look at
that and and I just think how could that have been
done where were the where where was there ever
like looking at like the fans and what they think
you know what do the fans think of this stuff are
they satisfying the fans most normal people don't
care you know like like is it entertaining taking
my family especially how expensive it is to the
movie theater experience which is is going away
right the theatrical experience of seeing a movie
is is going away you had better entertain me and
I think that whether Hollywood notices it or not
I think that people don't really like politics
woven into fairly mainstream which should be
mainstream entertainment experiences and I
think we're we're seeing that more and more
it's it's unbelievable to me I think
you're leaving money on the table
for for not giving what the customer is looking
for in that experience but so in my mind studios
there's no excuse to fail you have the best people
in marketing you have the most talented actors
craftsmen when it comes to special effects and
cinematography music there's no excuse for that to
fail and I think part of the failing of Hollywood
is that the marketing is so good sometimes
I've i've argued with friends sometimes that I
believe that that there should be a key art I mean
there are key art awards you know for key movie
poster art I'm a fan of movie poster art there's a
really good documentary about movie poster art
called 24x36 check out that documentary but you
know there there should almost be a a marketing
award and here's the problem the conundrum
the marketing for some for these movies is so good
the product doesn't live up to the marketing so
I mean I got chills watching the trailers for
the rise of skywalker I was so excited to see
that movie the ninth I mean I was a kid when I saw
Star Wars I'm seeing the ninth movie in this saga
I cannot believe how horrible it turned out
it's it's it's really to me it's malpractice
what happened to that franchise
and how it's divided fandom
fighting over things that are really
irrelevant I think I think it's it's well
not entirely irrelevant the fact that
they're just like you're seeing people
from within that company attack the fans just
like it's I hate to see it because I'm like
nerds are my people I go to San Diego comic-con
every year I have since the 90s gone to San Diego
comic-con and so to see people fractured over
this is really is really disheartening but when
it comes to studio movies there's no excuse not
to fail now when it comes to small indie movies
to make a good movie under those circumstances
without the resources without the money without
the great people in marketing without the budget
without all of the best of circumstances to make
an indie movie that like actually can can you can
be touched and moved by that is something to be
said which is why I've always gravitated toward
indie film you know it's a miracle when you see
something that's that's watchable out of a studio
but I don't I don't know like where the executives
I mean other than like maybe coming to mind like a
kevin feige which you know maybe his best days are
behind him you know I can't think of a studio
executive that is a visionary these days are
those the jocks the nerds or the the nerds of the
consumers yeah the jocks yeah I mean when we look
at like the era the the the 70s being the the last
great era of american filmmaking we really are
losing that american identity because we become
so fractured as a culture and I think that that
you know where's the movie that we all
love without debate that we've all loved
exactly I don't know that there
is one and and that's really
you know I really and at the end of the day I
miss loving Star Wars I miss loving it I used
to love it and now I'm saddened by that franchise
I'm using that as like the best example there's
a lot of other examples we could talk about the
terminator franchise we could talk about star trek
we can talk about these these sort of dead
franchises that have sort of lost their way
but when you look at like I just saw a documentary
called lady laddi about Alan Ladd the visionary
studio executive who basically greenlit Star Wars
and protected George Lucas I'm just afraid we're
never going to see another George Lucas right
we're never going to see another real creative
visionary that changes the industry because
everything is so corporate you know it's like what
did Francis Ford Coppola say factory filmmaking
that's that's the age in which we live there's
factory filmmaking which is a product and content
and then there's up-and-coming indie filmmakers
and you know when I talked about checking
those boxes earlier a lot of it is like is
it going to appeal international I mean let's
let's be honest the box office internationally
and especially in china is much bigger than
the united states that market those dollars
so you can't make a movie for the united states
anymore you have to make a movie for the world
which is fine but I think in in a way
that's sort of diluting our identity
as as a people as americans as we become more
fractured and it's it's distressing to see you
know you you see it when it's like when it's like
god I was having a conversation with a friend
because of course the movies are always an ongoing
conversation with friends if you're in my circle
you'll it it will come up and it's like when you
look at like when certain decisions are organic or
when you see when it's shoe horned in right when
when certain things are shoe horned in like like
a say the the trope that's become a trope now the
strong female lead it's just ripley was a great
character like just write a great character not
try to shoehorn in a type right and you kind of
know it when you see it you go oh this is cliche
this is a you're trying to shoehorn in a type
rather than like that's just a great character
you're also talking to a guy when I ever play
a video game I always choose a female character
I don't know why I just do that as someone who
has watched so many movies as someone who has made
their own films why do you think there's so many
bad films that are made well I look the reason
there's so many bad films these days is I think
one the barrier to entry is is much easier but I
also think that you're they're on that that's on
an indie level I see bad indie films too right
I usually want to want to help them and say
this was your lesson okay you'll make a better
movie in your second movie if you don't quit
but when it comes to studio films there's just
too many notes there are too many people that
it's sort of you know the modern day
ball player right like it's just like
it's not about the passion for
playing the game I'm not a passion of
you know hitting the ball and hearing the roar of
the crowd it's you know it's the licensing deals
and it's this and the sales of that and the
tv commercials and whatnot it's it's you know
i I when I look back at the movie the player which
came out when I first moved to los angeles robert
altman's the player things haven't changed the
subject has changed I mean that was sort of it was
erotic thrillers and you know it was julia roberts
and bruce willis were being cast in every movie
that was pitched in that film now it's superhero
movies but it's really too many cooks and I feel
like the people being you know elevated to these
positions are good executives but they're not
people that know the material the heart of the
material and when you look at the history of you
know creatives who really created something like a
George Lucas or a gene roddenberry things begin to
lose their way when they get sidelined right you
really need those I just I feel like the modern
day Hollywood now and especially with streaming
changing the game theaters the survival of
theaters being in doubt really we may live at a
time where maybe the billion-dollar blockbuster
may not be back for a long time and that may end
up being a good thing right like let's let's make
it's I always I'll joke with a friend and
I'll say my favorite spider-man movie is
the one where mary jane is in peril at the
end which is pretty much all the spider-man
movies or my favorite science fiction movie is
the movie where that thing blows up at the end
that's every science fiction movie right
which is why and the empire strikes back
with such a because it wasn't about we got to
do and blow up the thing that's boring it's
it's just creatively bankrupt which is why empire
strikes back holds up everybody says oh it's the
best Star Wars movie I mean you could argue but
it but it's yeah because it didn't do that thing
that happened in all the other movies and and so
trying to go against doing that thing it's it's
or fighting a blue light there's a lot of fighting
a blue light that happens in films fighting a blue
light saving the person at the end the thing that
blows up at the end and I say defy those cliches
at all costs and it's funny because you see
like you know there's still people that are
able to work within studio system and deliver
worthwhile films christopher nolan being among
them I've quite admired his work although he
has a tendency to make things a little overly
complex for no reason just to brag about how
smart he is but there's always a point in his
films and you'll notice that once I pointed out
where a character in a christopher nolan movie
will say we have to go down the thing and grab
the thing to do this and shoot this it's it's
captain narrative right it's the person that
stops the movie to tell you what's happening in
the movie to explain what's going to happen so the
audience the dumb audience understands it to me oh
so you got that studio now studio note and he
compromises in a way that doesn't completely
destroy what he's trying to achieve as a
filmmaker so he's willing to play ball but
I just see and I think you know the most
recent example being Zack Snyder's Justice
League and the fact that that universe will remain
unexplored unfortunately which is disheartening
you look at that and I think part of the reason
that Zack Snyder's Justice League was suppressed
was because you know once it came out and you see
these are the choices the studio executives made
they decided to hire Joss Whedon they decided
to change everything about it in in in you know
in exchange for this like it makes them look bad
right because what Zack Snyder was trying to do is
much much better clearly whether you enjoy it
personally or not it was objectively much better
than what Joss Whedon ended up coming up with
which was effectively a dumb cartoon a live-action
dumb cartoon so what about adaptations do you
think that that's has that always been around or
is that adaptations adaptations of popular books
not not necessarily doesn't have to be a franchise
but you know well I mean think about think about
it it's here's what's dead is originality I mean
people forget what George Lucas created in
Star Wars was something completely original
I mean yes it was influenced by so many things
westerns you know flash gordon and buck rogers
cereals and whatnot but but almost nothing that
you see isn't nothing that you see in the studio
realm it's all based on something pre-existing
material it's a book a graphic novel a comic book
a thing that kind of proved the concept right
and then or a franchise right it's a thing that
you know whether it's Star Wars star trek whatever
you know comic book characters that have been
around for years it's very rare that there'll
be something that's a wholly original concept
so I kind of you know I really it would really
be interesting if studios rolled the dice more
to get something like a joker what todd
phillips did with the joker right that
joker film which was a low-budget movie right I
mean I chatted with him about it I'm sure you can
look up quotes todd phillips talking about how he
he pitched them doing some sort of dc black series
it would be these sort of one-off films that would
be stories that didn't really fit with any sort of
larger continuity that were like smaller movies we
could explore a part of that universe and the fact
that that movie did so well you know from being
praised from uh you know in terms of at award
season I think is proves his concept was was the
right way to go and people forget todd phillips
came from independent film you know he I knew him
back in the day when he was making documentaries
he famously has that frat house documentary
that played sundance and then never was released
so I think you can find it on youtube what about
mink what's that what about mink mink yeah I don't
know how you make a mink you know like here's
the thing I look at mank and I'm like I love
menk but I went to film school and I've seen
citizen kane 100 times and I've read books about
citizen kane and one of my one of my favorite
dvd commentaries is the one that roger ebert did
for citizen kane so I know a lot of the back
story and I feel like it's almost impossible to
watch mank you have to watch citizen kane maybe
watch citizen kane first and then watch mank
and then re-watch citizen kane but yeah
I think mank is incredible you know
but I think it's for I think mank is for film
nerds I mean I think it's brilliant that david
fincher was able to get that film made in
the way that he made it you know it's sort
of an it's sort of a story about the genre made
within the style of the old school genre but with
modern tools and then sort of laced with political
commentary maybe a bit too heavy-handed at times
but I really enjoyed mank but it's not that's not
a mainstream audience movie so kudos to kudos to
netflix for that but yeah most of I wouldn't
say that you know I like to be an optimist
so I don't know that 99 of the studio movies
are bad maybe it's more like 97 we can we can
quibble about the percentages but you know stuff
leaks through that could be an ongoing podcast
why 99 of movies are garbage it's really
documenting all the mistakes that filmmakers make
I think I think one that I've seen as a trend that
I think I failed to mention in the previous video
was the gender swapping of of characters I
think that I mean you know I 've seen how
people think that that's a well we'll just do
a female terminator or we'll just do a female
you know a female version of x I always think it
it's better to start with an original character
and have a and and and approach it approach a
film that way I find it kind of pandering on
on hollywood's part to just we're just going
to do this franchise which we already know
is proven success and we're going to gender
swap the lead I think I think that's lazy
I think it's pandering to a certain audience
and that audience may not even really be there
and I think that that fans of those
franchises completely see through that
it's it's you know I mean the latest that mad max
movie that we did that that they did recently fury
road he's really kind of the side character but
what charlize theron did she created this amazing
new character I think they kind of that was
maybe the right way of doing that the wrong way
might have been the the you know terminator film
dark fate which I'm not sure who loved that movie
I know it didn't do too well at the box
office I mean sarah connor is already
an amazing character I don't know why you need
to you know flip things and gender swap I think
again I think audiences see audiences see through
that an example we talked about this earlier was
you know one that thankfully they'll hopefully
never do which is back to the future there's
been rumblings of bringing the back to the future
series and doing a reboot of back to the future
there was a rumor years ago and I pay very little
attention to rumors because most of them we all
know are bs but there was a strong rumor that
justin bieber was going to be in a reboot of
the back to the future series but that's a
franchise you I don't think you could ever
you could ever gender swap the lead the lead
like and call that lead mandy mcfly and having
some sort of weird relationship with a younger
version of her father would be very awkward
I mean that just doesn't work and and then there
are cases where gender swapping is irrelevant
for example the upcoming dune movie with timothy
chalamet there's a character named dr liet kinds
which I've read the novel obviously seen the 1984
david lynch film the gender of that character is
absolutely irrelevant not relevant to the
character whatsoever in in that case maybe
in in in some ways can kind of add to something
when you're doing it just to pander to an audience
audiences see through it I really see it I
really feel that when you are pandering whether
it's queerbaiting or you know gender-swapping
characters or race-swapping it's lazy it's lazy
you know i'd rather see more original characters
that are are you know maybe by female creators
black creators where are their voices if you're
simply taking you know creators who have done
things and just changing the gender or race I
find is lazy in that and I think that audiences
they're they're not really in favor of it you know
it it seems to not be working and I think I think
if Hollywood just leaned a little bit into
originality a little bit more into originality
and took some risks with new creators see that's
the thing that I think people don't understand is
that the original creators of those characters
they get money right they get money and so
I don't understand why there's not more of an
effort to find people who have created original
characters that are all across the spectrum of
ethnicity or gender and and make and make movies
with those characters right I mean the original
creators of those properties would profit so
i I think pandering is probably a a huge mistake
and underestimated how savvy audiences are that
they see through it so if I come in and say I want
to do a male version of heather's or jennifer's
body or mean girls you know I mean hey there's
mount there's male bullying there's all sorts
of stuff so it's john's body okay sure that's not
that's not probably gonna work or it's so blatant
that I'm flipping it here's the thing I've seen
that story so I've seen those stories changing the
gender is not gonna is sort of you know make me
care about the character because the point is is
this I you know I identify with so many characters
that aren't me right and I think that you have to
create something that comes from the essence of
what that character is ripley is a character I
loved as a kid ellen ripley played beautifully by
sigourney weaver in two and a half good movies but
but but you know I I think that just the the sort
of you know I think it's just lazy to do that but
it's an opportunity for an audience to identify
with someone that isn't them and I feel like
you have to as an audience member be capable
of seeing the world through someone else's eyes
and I 've said this before I don't know if
I've said it but in another video but like
you have to as an audience member have the
ability to identify with someone who's not
you that's how you know even the storytelling
is great if you can take just sort of a regular
dude like me and I can identify with a woman who's
maybe not a woman who's white so maybe not a woman
from the united states who's maybe a woman
that's going that to me is great storytelling
I would say another film that I thoroughly
loved amelie french film amelie right okay
not a woman I don't speak french you know a
lot of her experiences very different from mine
but I dentified with her I was on her journey and
so that to me is you know storytelling is great
when you know vastly different people can identify
with someone that is not is not themselves I don't
need to see me reflected in a film in fact I
prefer not to you know I want to see someone
new and interesting and different and I think
that what's lacking in the storytelling is is is
making these stories universal so the gender and
ethnicity is irrelevant it should be irrelevant
yeah I mean just you had said earlier
about the the marty mcfly character
turned into danny mcfly and you're right it it
wouldn't work for the especially for the one
fact of of flipping it with the dad now to have
a biff character that's female that's bullying
her that actually would be interesting and and
and then her sort of going on this journey and
playing in a band see now you're being like
a studio executive and you're you're pitching
the female back to the future please please
please I will say this to camera which I know
my eye line is you but I'm going to say the
camera please if you're a studio executive you're
watching this do not ruin back to the future do
not ruin back to the future by making a female
back to the future it would be terrible think
about it deeply this is not a good idea seek out
original ideas from original creators
who have original stories to tell please
please so I don't have to do a
third version of this video please
why are there so many bad sequels
there are so many bad sequels because I feel
like the essence of what made the original
so interesting is the thing that's not really
focused on usually what's focused on in a sequel
is more and it's more spectacle not the thing that
made it compelling to begin with I think the way
to answer this question is to look at the sequels
that that you know succeeded films like the
godfather two right godfather two you know was an
even more complex film than the original godfather
it tells it it plays with time where you're having
two stories being told simultaneously the story of
vito corleone his rise to power you know along
with you know the pres the present-day michael
corleone who's you know you're seeing his story
play out in present-day that the story is being
told and it's also different and it's original in
the same way that the first godfather was original
I could apply that same thing to
Star Wars and the empire strikes back
the empire strikes back ended on a cliffhanger
the original Star Wars ended with this triumphant
ending the good guys win when did the good
guys ever lose in a fairy tale generally never
but the empire strikes back did that
it didn't even tell a complete story
you know and at the time you had to wait three
years to to see what the conclusion of that
story would be so doing something original and
different rather than more of the same which would
have been let's have another death star which
of course they did twice more in Star Wars films
you know I mean maybe three times if you want
to count rogue one but going over old territory
is boring and I feel like what you need to do
is in the same way that the original film was
a risk in doing something original if you're
going to do a sequel you also need to take
risks and do something different I would I would
say that this doesn't apply as much but with alien
and aliens alien directed by ridley scott aliens
james cameron one's more horror set in outer
space the other one is action movie more aliens
right but it's a different type of film and a
continuation of that story told with with some
originality that's another sequel that holds up
but so many other sequels that I have not named
are terrible for the very reason that they just
try to give you more of what was in the first
one rather than you know defy your expectations
and and that I think has to do with fear on
the part of the filmmakers and not really
trusting the audience I think you need to
trust the audience that they want to see these
beloved characters from the first film in new and
different situations things that are challenging
to those characters and and you don't often see
that in sequels it's just more I think that's lazy
as much as the Fast and the Furious movies
are financially successful I don't know if
you could call any of them critically acclaimed
those films tend to do well but it's just more
craziness it's more over the top it's more
in the last one they go to outer space
how much more over the top can you get it's just
it's ridiculous now I mean at this point just take
you know a friend of mine once suggested just take
the drivers from Fast and the Furious and put them
in the transformers cars they're driving the
transformers cars why not combine franchises
it would at least be original right but
I think if you're going to do a sequel
you've got to do something different and
original because that's keeping with the
characters I need to challenge the characters in
ways they were not challenged in the first film
and I'm not saying that's something easy but
when you look at what a successful sequel is
compared to one that is completely forgettable
they made of the fly too the fly with
jeff goldblum they made a sequel to it
gina davis's character dies in like the opening
scene no one there there's many sequels I could
I could name off the top of my head you
would not even remember that there was a
sequel the highland highlander two there was
a sequel I think there's like nine of those
but the only one that really holds up is the
first one so it's it's very tricky it's very
tricky I feel like it's important to to be
original in the same way that the first one
what what people liked about that flip that
defy expectations I'll go back several decades
but staying alive and saturday night fever
and I know I'm really dating myself here but
both fantastic films staying alive to me I'm sorry
yeah staying alive was was a little bit better
in my sense than than saturday night fever just
because I enjoyed john travolta's journey staying
in this crummy hotel he's this hungry dancer he
meets finola hughes who's got this upper hand
and can help him but there are strings attached
it's just a fantastic cast of characters and to
me I thought that the the storytelling was was
richer but again that's it's going back several
years it's not a franchise I understand that
some of the viewers may not know that movie
but I thought that the storytelling was was way
better but I yeah do you remember that I remember
it and I wish I could forget it oh you do okay
it was that bad no it just that I mean that film
I just remember the phenomenon being the music I
remember it was r-rated and I could not go see it
so okay you know at the the time that saturday
night fever came out sure sure yes I think I
remember that too but I think I saw it when I
was a little bit older but the staying alive
for me just I thought that the continuation of his
journey as this like you know here he was this hot
shot back home but then he goes to the big city
and he's just this small fish in this very very
treacherous pond where no one's trustworthy and
everybody has their own agenda and the gir the
good girl cynthia gibbs she actually seems like
the best character and he's like whatever with
you because she can't she can't get him anywhere
so I just thought it was just a great play on
on things but yeah I realize that's not
a franchise that's a great cameo from
sylvester stallone in the beginning by the way so
I mean look here's here's here's another reason
to me that sequels tend to suck is that the first
film generally is is made to not be a series the
first film is is is being made to tell a story and
it's usually being made for a reason that this is
there's there's meaning behind it there's purpose
on on behalf of the filmmaker that wants to tell
a story that has themes that are woven into the
film that that the filmmaker wants to express
so generally an original film that ends up being a
you know part of a series unintentionally you know
that that original film is being made
out of some reason that that is artistic
and sequels are made for money so by you know by
that very you know because of that dynamic sequels
are made for money original films that end up
being part of a series are usually made to express
something an artist is trying to say that always
mucks up what a sequel will be interestingly
yes I am going to come back to Star Wars George
Lucas had alan dean foster come up with a story
for a low-budget independent sequel to Star Wars
which was to be called splinter of the mind's eye
it ended up being a novel you can find it used
in a bookstore yeah a bookstore probably a
used bookstore you know go into one they're great
books are these things it's like the internet but
on really thin slices of wood try it someday in
any case this book was written to be a low budget
sequel to Star Wars because what George Lucas
wanted to do is you know if Star Wars bombed
he wanted to make a small indie follow-up
to that movie to continue the series and he
wanted it written in a way that that could be done
inexpensively it's really interesting to see what
what Star Wars might have been if splinter the
mind's eye was made as a low-budget indie movie
there's love to see a lot of those but
but but but you know I truly believe that
sequels because they are made purely because
accountants at a studio say this will make money
because if it makes 40 of the original it'll
be in profits if we scale the budget to this
which is why the budgets generally for sequels
are less money being spent than the original you
know because there is a formula used by studios to
say well the movie made x the first movie made x
if we scale the budget to this and it just
makes even 40 of the original will be in profits
you know that old formula is different
these days now with with so many other
pathways for films to make money but but
generally the sequel the budget is less
did you see Wonder Woman 1984
yes I saw Wonder Woman in 1984. okay
first off did you used to watch the show
I did I did used to watch the linda carter show
and I love that show okay it's it's it's fun it's
you know it's wholesome there's a weird subtext
I didn't notice when I was a kid but now I see it
if you know something about the history of Wonder
Woman and that character but but yes I saw Wonder
Woman and I did see Wonder Woman 1984. is this
pg-13 can you tell me the subtext well it's all
about it's all about bdsm and fetish stuff it was
always like Wonder Woman getting tied up or Wonder
Woman tying up with the lasso gotcha you know
whoever the adversary was to make them tell the
truth okay it was this is not an original thought
of mine this is all very well documented go down
your own rabbit hole on the internet but feel free
to jump off okay at some point so aside from the s
m angle to it which that's its own show what
what do you what do you think fell short
in 1984 the second I think what fell short was
was logic on behalf of the filmmakers I mean
they really there was a the thing that really
fell short was a believability you know you can
wish things and they come true I think it's kind
of a maybe an idea that should have been vetted it
sounds kind of sounds kind of dumb to me like
it just I just didn't believe it whereas yeah
I believe a woman who's an amazonian could be
imbued with these powers but Wonder Woman isn't
Wonder Woman because of her powers she's because
of her because of her character and her morality
because of her commitment to you know defending
those that are powerless you know against the
from the powerful and I feel that that essence
of her character was kind of captured maybe a
little bit in the opening scene which I thought
was kind of cute and clever and and the opening
scene of Wonder Woman 84 is kind of harking
back to a richard donner superman you know
I I enjoyed that it was kind of cute and
goofy I'll take it it's fine once it got
into the the main plot with pedro pascal just
sort of defied logic and and the the way that
that you know you know chris pine's character was
brought back it was I just thought was ridiculous
I don't I don't know if the gender was reversed
it was done the other way it might have worked
it might even be somewhat offensive you know sort
of like if they made a female back to the future
let's say if they they rebooted the
franchise let's say we're going to
reboot the franchise back to the future let's
just think about how we would do that right
and it's a female back to the future sure and
marty her name is mandy right and she goes back
and there's a sexual tension between her dad
or who will be her dad a younger version of
her dad I don't think that will work yeah
that's a little creepy it's a little creepy
so maybe it's a really good thing it's a good
thing that back to the future franchise may be one
of the only franchises that will not be rebooted
because if you did reboot back to the future with
a female mandy right and well I guess it could
be doc brown not gonna work it just doesn't work
sure please Hollywood realize that it's not going
to work because we've seen these franchises get
rebooted and it's disheartening to
me when you see the number of movies
made it's always based on pre-existing material
and the reason Hollywood does this is because
ideas must be vetted in some form it was a play
it was a novel it's a franchise which is generally
the answer it's a franchise that's existed for 80
years 50 years 40 years whatever it is right like
it's vetted if you're going to invest that
kind of money you know it's just it's you know
you want to make sure you have your
best chance of being profitable
so I understand from their thinking but
it really does it does quell what might
be some amazing original ideas that's why I I 'm
upset that we may never see a type of filmmaker
like George Lucas again of creating a fantasy
world from nothing as an original series of movies
I mean Star Wars was certainly inspired by
everything from marvel comics dr doom's character
darth vader from flash gordon the serials
from dune the book by frank herbert it was
inspired by so many things it's like a blender of
all this cool [ __ ] into something that's
original and risk is not something Hollywood likes
let's talk about killing iconic characters
when is it okay when is it a horrible mistake
I think it's really important if you want to
retain the audience for a franchise how you kill
off an iconic movie character absolutely critical
and there are places in movie history where it's
been done right and there are places where it's
been done completely wrong and it's been bungled
I I it's it's upsetting to me I mean first
of all the death of an iconic fictional
character is already upsetting just on its face
let's talk about a case in which it was done
incredibly well in star trek ii the wrath of khan
you're taking leonard nimoy's character spock
who he'd played you know for decades by then
and you're now killing off this character
you're killing off spock it's handled so well
it's not a wasteful death spock dies in an act of
self-sacrifice trying to save the crew of the
enterprise which he'd done many times before
and skirted death now he's you know dying in the
engine room of the enterprise facing his best
friend jim kirk because the important thing to
remember and this is something for screenwriters
to keep in mind is that the death of the
character is not about the person doing the dying
it's about the reaction of the characters that
love the character that's that's going through
and experiencing their death and so what we got
to experience as an audience was two longtime
friends and an active self-sacrifice spock is
dying and he gets to say his final words to kirk
and kirk gets to see his friend in addition to
that that scene is followed up with a funeral with
some glorious music and and I mean we didn't know
at the time that they were setting up a sequel
star trek three the search for spock which kind of
gives it away that spock might be coming back but
be that as it may no one's ever dead in in fiction
but the way that that death was handled with
was handled with such respect for all
the characters involved we got it was a
satisfying in the sense that we experienced the
love that james t kirk has for his friend spock
and then the reactions of people who loved spock
and and how they were affected by his death
his death had meaning conversely one of the
worst deaths ever handled in movie history
was the death of han solo in the force awakens
you know many people were upset with the last jedi
and how luke skywalker's character was handled but
the thing that lost it for me was han
solo's death and the force awakens
it's not done in any sort of act of self-sacrifice
there isn't a moment where other
characters can react to han solo's death
he's simply you know dispensed with by his own
son ben solo with a lightsaber to the heart
and then falls down an endless chasm generally
falling down an endless chasm is the kind of
death that usually a villain experiences leading
cause of death amongst villains I'm sure there's
an infographic somewhere on the internet that
will tell you this because that's how the emperor
died in the original return of the jedi episode
six that's how villains go out falling into an
endless chasm we don't really see the bloodiness
it's off-screen that's how a villain goes out
and to have han solo die in that way and not have
a last moment with chewbacca his loyal friend to
not have a last moment with princess leia or luke
skywalker the audience was completely betrayed
of any meaning for that death was betrayed by
not being able to see our beloved characters who
just if you're watching all the movies in in order
a few hours ago was alive and well and saving the
universe and my god if there was a child and we
had just finished watching return of the jedi
I don't know that i'd want to skip to the next
movie to see what happens because what happened
how the character of han solo was treated in his
death in the force awakens was offensive to me
and told me that this franchise was in the
wrong hands because you can't take a character
like that and have him go out that way you know
it's not it's not a bad thing and this used to
be yes it's a Hollywood trope you know riding
off into the sunset was was a fine way to go
right it worked for shane it worked it worked
for many iconic Hollywood films we're gonna ride
off into the sunset maybe we don't need to see
the death we can imagine other adventures with
that character but their story has been told and
they can ride off into the sunset but if you're
actually going to kill an iconic character it
needs to be done with some level of respect
and every way that that could have been handled
in a much better way which would be the to have
some final words they could have even done it in
that movie he could have been mortally wounded
by ben thinking he could have turned his
son back from the dark side to the light
and he was mortally wounded and you can imagine a
scene with luke skywalker and princess
leia over you know a dying han solo
and what the words that might have been said we'll
never see that now so I I'm just I'm just offended
by that and so I think that that's if you look at
those two cases of spock and his sacrifice in star
trek ii the wrath of khan just go watch that scene
and then you compare it with the scene of han solo
meaningless without even a funeral and even
though the when when when rey returns and
you know there's the knowledge that han solo you
know is dead she she just goes to hug ray not
not like you know chewbacca who she's known
for decades I know that I don't understand
so I really question the thinking of some
of the people in charge who are overseeing
some of these beloved franchises and how that
affected not just children who these movies
are really made for children or for older dudes
like myself who saw the classic films as a kid
and would at least like these characters
to be treated with some level of respect
george lucas famously consulted
a child psychologist when he
toyed with the idea of making darth
vader the father of the hero of his movie
right he he was I don't know I want to see how
this is going to affect kids was there any vetting
done by how this might affect the audience if
you're going to handle this death in that way
and in each of the sequel trilogy
movies the deaths of the characters
are are are handled with this not not using
what I would consider to be a respectful
death which is there needs to be someone to
react to that death that is meaningful in that
in that character's life and of course spock's
best friend in the universe was jim kirk
so when he made that sacrifice it was meaningful
and han solo's sacrifice seemed like a waste
something else that occurs to me also related to
Star Wars yes a recurring topic in conversations
that I will have with you and
that I have with my friends often
you know maybe it's a form of therapy
but but what was interesting was
that when George Lucas was mapping out
the story for the empire strikes back
he realized that the audience would never
believe that you would kill luke skywalker
so you have this lightsaber duel at the end of
the empire strikes back and it's luke skywalker
fighting darth vader where's the tension
because we already know he's making a trilogy
you're not going to kill off luke skywalker so
there's really no drama or tension in that scene
so what lucas did he's like okay since they the
audience is not going to believe that I would
kill luke skywalker what if the real drama
the real threat is that luke might turn to
the dark side and because he he he doesn't listen
to yoda's advice he doesn't complete his training
he goes off as a as as not a fully trained jedi
and faces his greatest nemesis who he then learns
at the end of the after losing that fight that
it's his father could he turn to the dark side
and and George Lucas believed that the audience
might believe that he would turn to the dark side
and and therein lies the tension whereas many
of the lightsaber duels that take place in
in the sequel trilogy are are kind of meaningless
so it's important for these characters
and I would say that if you're a disney
shareholder you probably care even more
if you want a franchise to to continue to exist
and be profitable and you want to sell more han
solo shirts and whatnot that that the deaths
of iconic movie characters be treated with
respect and it's an opportunity not just for the
fictional characters that love that character in
that world to say goodbye it's an opportunity
for the audience to say goodbye as well
reminds me of a film I watched recently I think
or late 90s early 2000s and it's about a Hollywood
producer and it shows a test screening and sean
penn is one of the the characters in the film
playing you know he is sean penn in the movie
and it's the famous thing of at the end he gets
killed but does his dog so they show it to this
test audience and they're horrified and it's
a horrific scene it's awful and so that is the
big dilemma in the film do we keep that scene in
and I think robert de niro plays the Hollywood
producer I think it's called like what the hell
happened or something like that it's got an
all-star cast but where I'm going with this is
test screenings and audience feedback if you feel
this way and other fans do as well why was nothing
done why was the respect given to one character
dying not so for the other I mean I mean there's
there's actually interesting documentary that
I just saw about alan ladd jr called lady
it's it's actually made by his daughter and of
course alan ladd jr was instrumental in getting
Star Wars made but he famously gave a lot
of notes to to movies like the exorcist and
whatnot like he would give very small notes
he wasn't like telling filmmakers what to
do he was more like okay we're watching
this in a screening room and like okay
but there's this element missing sometimes it's
you know it's important to take that step back
and I do believe that test audiences test
audiences can actually help improve a film
I know that you know for example you know
I mean they call them focus groups quentin
tarantino has a more colorful colorful term
for focus groups he calls them fuckus groups
but I know I said I wouldn't swear but but but
I think that I think that it's important to
you know to to keep those kinds of feelings
and there's a lot of feelings wrapped up
in in an audience's experience with
this that's why I think these these
death scenes are so so critical the
approach to it I 'm just surprised that
the legacy characters from the previous trilogy
which if you're doing a marathon or just
you know were treated so poorly that there there
wasn't as much thought given to that you know
I you know you people have invested we're talking
about the movies here but also we're also talking
about there are comic book stories about these
characters there are stories I've made up in my
mind about these characters yes when I played with
action figures when I was a kid you know there are
stories we made up in our heads there are novels
there are radio plays there are all sorts of
stories that this that these iconic characters
have you know have participated in and and we've
experienced those we there's a lot invested
so the callousness with which that was done is
shocking to me to this day I tend to connect
with people the easiest way to connect is through
a passion for film and all types of film I
really am I do think it's important that we have
a balanced media diet oh what is that a balanced
media diet is absolutely critical in the same
way that what we put into our bodies is just
as important if you lived only on fast food
say Hollywood blockbuster movies I find that
first of all if you only ate mcdonald's there's
already been a movie made about that and
it doesn't do good things to your body
right like fast food greasy food not
good for you balance and I feel like
we don't pay enough attention to our media diet
and the media diet has to be yes fine I'm gonna
go see that marvel movie right I'm gonna go
see that movie that a lot of movie these days
they're just like theme park rides they're
not movies right they're selling products
and I'm gonna balance that out by seeing a really
amazing documentary or a small independent film
made by a filmmaker I've never heard of put out
like by a gravitas ventures or something or a 1091
or 824 one of these other companies well 824
is warner brothers that's another story but
the orchard the orchard yeah a24 is very good
taste if you ask oh they do I really do love
their the their how they curate the films that
they put out or an ifc participant yeah yeah like
like have a balanced media diet if you there's
a whole group of youtubers that are on that that
have made a living [ __ ] on giant franchises
and I say I agree with first of all I agree with
many of them those franchises are terrible the
modern incarnations of some of these franchises
that have been around more than 20 years they've
sort of run it into the ground but I feel like
maybe you wouldn't be as upset about them
if you had a balanced media diet meaning
meaning yeah I'll see the latest whatever
forgettable big blockbuster movie
but because I have seen some smaller film
this is a weird example psycho gourmand
you know or a movie a documentary I would highly
recommend called clapboard jungle which is about
it's about a filmmaker's journey trying
to you know actually find a way to make
money in this in crazy industry I think you
need to have a balanced media diet and that's
at least what my mission is with film thread is
we tend to champion filmmakers who make these
smaller movies because there are plenty of other
websites that cover Star Wars marvel pixar disney
right those are all one company if I right marvel
pixar Star Wars disney that's all one company
putting out the stuff there really is a monopoly
it's it's unfortunate that these big blockbusters
have that but but those are okay to
see but you should not only see those
it's just like you know within like see
one of those and then see a smaller film
see one of those see a documentary see
one of those see another documentary like
break it up and really look like whether it's
like you're scrolling through itunes or vudu or
whatever one of those services where you can
purchase or rent movies and look at the you
know video on demand stuff that's just come
out you're gonna find some incredible stuff
and and that's where I feel very fortunate and
that's part of our mission is to say look at these
movies because if you only lived off the giant
franchise films you will find only disappointment
and so and so break it up a bit maybe you won't be
as upset about that so have a balanced media diet
so there's four food groups and there's four
like you know you have your blockbusters you
have your documentaries you have your art house
and then maybe something with subtitles sure okay
I actually you know what I will say this
I put subtitles on when I don't have to
because you learn so much when I watched game of
thrones I knew all the characters names because I
watched it with with the closed captioning on it's
great it's it's really it's really fantastic so I
actually recommend closed captioning even if it's
a film that's in your the the language that you're
familiar with your native language is it's you
you you'll you'll learn more because especially
because a lot of it is like you'll get some of the
direction that's directly out of the screenplay
right like like it's really useful and thinking
like a writer I think that watching a movie with
closed captioning on in english even if you are
an english speaker is really useful so I tend
to do that I don't know is that I don't know if
that's a thing I do it my thing I have friends who
think I'm crazy for doing it I find it incredibly
you'll learn a lot more about what you're watching
I like ideas that provoke my sensibilities
you know I like some something a piece of art
that will challenge me I know that there's
you know I feel that like there's a lot of
you know to me fiction fiction is all about
being able to identify with whoever or whatever
is on screen whether that person that I'm seeing
in this work of fiction whether it's a book
movie television show whatever it is I don't
need to be that person I just need to identify
with that person it may not be my same gender may
not be the same ethnicity or nationality as me
and not speak the same language
as I may not even be human
right but the point of all fiction is that we
identify with the protagonist and it doesn't have
to match who I am in fact I prefer that usually
doesn't I mean I remember being mocked when I
was younger whenever I play video games I always
chose female characters I don't know why I think
I just like to look at the female form in a video
game but I always chose the female characters I
tend to I'm playing right now the video game I'm
playing and obsessed with and it's been wrongly
I think mocked for a lot of its technical issues
is the the game cyberpunk 2077 which I think is
a brilliant brilliant game it really immerses
you in this you know open world adventure game
and I'm playing as a female version of a character
and I think it's I think it's amazing I think that
there's I think I think we learn by identifying
with someone who who doesn't match my my exact
circumstances I think a lot of this comes from
my mother when I was younger and I would just
see whatever mainstream stuff was at the movie
theater I lived bicycle distance to a movie
theater where I grew up in royal oak michigan
and I would ride my bike to the berkeley theater
or the main theater or the americana theater which
was a further bike ride but I would I would I
would go see movies and she would tell me don't
just go see movies that are at the mall theater
go to the art house she encouraged me to go to
the maple theater which was where their art house
theater was and I saw films that had subtitles you
know I mean I grew up watching a lot of uh toho
monster movies right and and you know japanese
television shows so I had this you know by the
time I was like in my late teens early 20s i'd
seen a lot of foreign films and a lot of a lot of
just different types of movies across
the board not just your traditional
big mainstream movies like your Star Wars and your
alien and and you know disney cartoons and whatnot
so back to having a balanced media diet and I
think that's important and I think it's important
and I think I think I know when a writer's
been successful when someone that I would
not have ever had that experience where
I can just be totally with that person
experiencing the world through their eyes and
I'm I don't look like that person I think that is
really powerful to be able to create a character
protagonist that anyone can identify with
so I think that's important to keep in mind here's
a thought have movies lost their cool because
television has become so good so if you think
back to growing up tv was was more restricted
and and everything cool happened in movies like
kramer versus kramer ooh there were some scenes
that I wasn't supposed to see but I saw them
anyway right now you can see it all on tv yeah
I do think that television has succeeded so well
when it comes to you know long-form storytelling
I do think that there is a bit of abuse in that
where I've seen series that were six episodes six
hours that would have made a really good two hour
movie but I think that there's an appetite for the
serialized long-form storytelling and and we've
become used to that we've become used to the binge
watching so going to the theater to see you know
a story that's gonna wrap itself up in hopefully
two hours maybe it's not as satisfying and even
you know when you look at the Star Wars films or
the marvel movies it really is just every marvel
movie is a continuation of the last marvel movie
in some form because we know there's going to be
easter eggs we know there's going to be you know
cameos from characters so marvel movies in a sense
have become not only its own genre but you know a
sort of a form of long-form storytelling with
the disney plus series the you know those kind of
filling in the blanks between movies but I think
that television is is great I mean television
is where nudity in movies has migrated there's
hardly nudity in films anymore I mean it's it's
you know you're gonna sacrifice something at the
box office if you choose to include adult themes
in your feature film being released
to theaters if there's nudity in it
you know that has migrated onto television you
know it's a golden as mr skin who was recently on
the film threat podcast told me it's a golden age
of nudity in television not so much at the movies
you know there aren't like the genre of
teen sex comedy kind of doesn't even exist
people people forget that the original porky's
film such as it was yes it does feature nudity
but also there's a you know underlying message
of anti-semitism woven within that film that of
course no one remembers except for me I remember
this I don't know why I remember weird facts
but that but you know maybe this is also why
television part of the reason that television
in a way is more popular than than films I don't
know if anyone's ever done this study I would love
to see because I think box office is an irrelevant
metric by which to to look at it's something the
industry uses as a piece of marketing I
don't like that box office is so important
it tends to be to Hollywood because it's again
a piece of marketing my mother who doesn't pay
attention to the industry whatsoever she knows
what the number one movie at the box office is
because it's used in the marketing of movies right
but that's not an important number because that
number is is irrelevant because due to inflation
if adjusted to inflation and you can look this up
gone with the wind is in the top films not
whatever the top the purported top films are
right I so I you know because we're not privy to
a lot of the data from these streaming services we
really don't know what is incredibly popular but
they wouldn't be making so many of these series
if they weren't at least getting numbers
that got the eyeballs they needed to
be somewhat profitable but but we're we're
but because we're as the general public not
privy to those numbers there aren't we're not
given other than the people who have access
to those to that data we're not able to learn the
lessons from that there are lessons to be learned
about the failure of something
like terminator dark fate right
there's a lesson to be learned there I don't
think hollywood's quite learned the lesson yet so
you know that's kind of how we learn right
you see what resonates with an audience
and box office is one barometer of that adjusted
to inflation I think is is the better way to
to report those numbers do you have more
hope for the future of television or film
i I certainly have hope for the
future of television there are
I think that statistically speaking if I watch
something on television and I vet that choice
the you know the idea that I'll have a good
experience with a show based on recommendations
friend recommendations tends to tends to to
hit more often than not with the movies not
so much with the movies it's probably 50 50 or
less you know that will be a decent experience
if I know what I'm getting into I am a person that
does enjoy a good bad film why good good bad films
are just I mean look there's certain kind of
television that is made for stoners right I mean
like I think a show like archer that's the
animated show archer that's that's like stoner tv
I mean you know most of the adult swim shows
are for stoners right they're sort of a good
bat I mean like tim and eric their show is kind of
based on that right so and there are films I tend
to like but I know that they're bad trauma movies
you know by lloyd kaufman one of the longest
you know existing independent film studios is
trauma studios you know what you're getting into
you also should be aware that james gunn
from the suicide squad and the guardians
of the galaxy franchise he began his career
at troma studios he wrote tromeo and juliet
so I kinda like if I know it's gonna be bad it's
not like something that's gonna change my life
but I will laugh and I don't have to be fully
engaged in it except for you know maybe the
scenes where there's lots of gore or violence
which you can always count on in a trauma movie
but that's the place where a lot of people cut
their teeth is in the exploitation genre everyone
from james gunn Francis Ford Coppola ron howard
who famously you know worked for roger corman
it's a place you can play and it's okay to fail
and it's it's you know and and to learn the
basics I think it's just as important to
watch a bad film and take the lessons
from it as it is to watch a good film
so the night why are 99 of movies garbage well
you know sometimes they're sometimes garbage
movies are made on purpose there's a there's
a big business in that just ask lloyd kaufman
or charlie band full moon entertainment you
know famously done most famously known for the
puppet master series love the puppet
master films they're they're dumb fun so
so I think it's kind of like just knowing what
you you know you can't eat steak for dinner
at every meal right sometimes some fast food
or quick meals are going to work their way in
and that's what I consider a bad movie I just
want to know I'm getting one unlike terminator
dark fate where I go into every movie hopeful go
into every movie hopeful it's going to be awesome
and it's it's not when an artist wins a razzy
how much of it do you think was actually planned
or none of it I mean does anyone really want to
win I don't I don't know that anyone ever wants
to win a razzie I mean showgirls wanna razzy
and and you know I mean that film actually
we look at now there's so much more going on
in that film show girls there are bad movies that
age differently maybe they were ahead of its time
they're ahead of their time like a film like the
original blade runner or a film like show girls
that like there was much more going on beneath the
surface I mean the trans community in particular
has embraced the movie showgirls as just having
much deeper meaning there's a documentary that
discusses this that I highly recommend that you
check out called you don't know me nomi check
out that documentary that's a a whole deep dive
analysis of show girls sort of re-examination
of that additionally like why there's a whole
fandom around showgirls which I find fascinating
great documentary that breaks that apart and looks
at it but we just don't know like what's gonna
what's gonna age well with time right like what's
going to defy what will be a cult classic which
no filmmaker wants to win a razzy or have
a film that's called a cult classic because
both of those things imply that you failed
and I don't think I've ever met a filmmaker
that tried to make a bad movie although I will
say this john waters has a great quote about that
john waters said you know if you try to make
a bad film you can't fail what does a good
opening of a movie have to have it's just really
simple I want to know what's going to happen next
and I and I can't tell you how many times
I've seen the first 5 or 10 minutes of a movie
and I don't want to watch the rest of it for a
couple years I was a programmer at the sonoma
valley film festival and was a program director
and I watched films and you can tell within
the first few minutes I you re you want to know
what's going to happen next you have to be engaged
you you have to be drawn in it's got to
be something emotional you have to connect
and and you just really have to know what hap
what's gonna happen next you can have like I
mean look you can have like a great opening
and and that can actually if you don't have
that great opening it's not gonna propel the rest
of the film because the middle of the movie can
get muddled I think middles of films are tough
but if you blow the opening I mean there's no
point in watching the rest I can't tell you how
many first 10 minutes of movies I've watched
so you have to grab the viewer in the first 10
minutes and it really comes to do I want to know
do I want to continue on the
story with this this character
can you think of one that's like the perfect
opening that stands out as a model that you would
never feel you could live up against see my taste
is so weird I'm a terrible person to ask that
question of what's what's a great opening but I'll
say that probably one of my favorite independent
films of all time is richard linklater's
slacker it's a totally non-traditional narrative
it follows different people's stories
sort of set in a day in austin texas
it's very much a the flavor of that town at
that time and I love that movie I don't know
what it is I think it's you know some of the
stories are more engaging than others but just
just I want to live in that world so so that's a
terrible example because it's not a traditional
narrative structure it's a series of pieces of
stories leading you through slice of life truly
slice of life but god what are three mistakes
that most filmmakers or screenwriters make
in the first act of a film I well I would
say that the biggest mistake that I see
that a filmmaker will make in the first act is
sort of a lack of world building to me I would
say that this probably applies more to genre
pictures world building is incredibly important
to set up those rules set up expectations and defy
those expectations and and if you if you have not
established that nothing in the you know the rest
of the film is going to work so in that first act
world building incredibly important what are
you looking for in a story what I always look
for in a story is take me on a journey and
make me feel something I want to feel moved
I don't have to agree with everything in the
film but I want to be taken on a journey where
I'll feel different out the other side
I think the films that have always
like impressed me the most are the ones
that have just made me look at life
differently there's a short list of films that
fit that category I would say that spike lees do
the right thing is one for me that I remember
when I saw that film when I was a kid it blew
my mind it changed my change my perspective of
the world it has an incredible opening scene
with that that music blaring it's just like
it's it's that title sequence is so incredible
but it also there's a sweetness to that world and
it's it's it's such a it's such an original vision
I don't know like like I remember seeing that film
and just feeling different afterwards and and I
mean that applies to other like more mainstream
movies like a Star Wars you know or a lord of the
rings but make me feel something make you know
move me in some way and and surprise me make
me want to go on this journey and then you know if
we're lucky I've I have a changed perspective what
is the purpose of story wow that is such a that's
such a these are big questions you're asking
i I really believe that the purpose of stories
is for us to experience things we
may never experience in our lifetime
as a way for us to heal based on our own personal
experience so experiencing a story that may have
to do with the death of a loved one may
help myself deal with the loss of a loved
one in my own life I feel like there's almost
films when I've talked to friends and they'll
say they're going through some you know trouble
you know whether it be work related or you know
love life or or whatnot or something tragic
that's happened I often prescribe a movie because
through the experience of a character in a
film we can help heal a part of ourselves
and that's what I think story is about to
to impart those lessons in a way that's safe
you know I've never been to war you know
I've never experienced what it's like to be
in war I've had relatives my grandfather fought
in world war ii he was in the navy I had an uncle
who was in vietnam and you know having never gone
through that experience I won't know what that's
like but having experienced films like saving
private ryan dunkirk some of the great war films
platoon among others you know oliver stone's
platoon like I you know those visceral war films
really put you in that seat full metal jacket by
stanley kubrick like so that comes to mind I'm
grateful that I've never you know had that kind
of experience but I do think that that really
the purpose is to for to teach us things and
to hopefully teach us something about ourselves
and a really good movie it's just a very personal
experience that's why I think people get offended
by bad reviews and by that I mean as someone who
has spent a good chunk of my career as a critic
what's weird is the reaction of people
when they look at your reviews for example
no one gets angry at someone
who gives a bad review to a car
in consumer reports or a bad review of a food
from a restaurant right but when it comes to
something like film if you give a bad review it's
like a personal attack but I believe I like when
someone has a completely different opinion from
my own I feel it's an opportunity for me to learn
something about that person I don't I wouldn't say
to someone who disagrees with me about an opinion
that I have about a film that they're wrong I
want to hear what their justifications are for
how they came to that conclusion but I do find
it humorous sometimes that people will be angry
for having a strong opinion about a movie
I think that that's a personal choice and
i I so I find that very strange do you think that
you're able to withstand punches more maybe some
people are too sensitive yeah I do think that
me not giving a [ __ ] is really helpful in
the sense that it's like it's like a shield that
protects me from just not caring what other people
think I think that that's I think the longer
you think what other people think that can be
that can be creatively crippling and so I try
to avoid that at all costs try to avoid like
giving a [ __ ] what people think I mean you know
it's it's a worthless exercise I like that writing
a prescription for cinema yeah I mean look I've
had friends that are just like oh you're going
through this oh you should watch that movie with
george clooney up in the air you just lost your
job that one was good jerry maguire is probably
good too you know what I mean like life is a house
yeah just yeah stuff like like it's just like
yeah I mean you know here's a prescription
for you're going through this thing
having a problem like an anne landers column
which I don't even know if that exists anymore
like an advice column but you're
prescribing movies instead of advice
but yeah I know there's certain movies
like I'll watch over and over again
that I think kind of helped me I mean I know for
a fact like it is there is there is such a thing
as movie therapy and that's why I think that
people you know that's why I think that this
this medium's not going away it's certainly
going to evolve in terms of the way we see it
but yeah take two steel magnolias call me in the
morning yeah exactly yeah exactly my 10 favorite
movies is an impossible question and I would be
like a I would probably short circuit I will tell
you what one of my all-time favorite independent
films is which is the original slacker directed
by richard linklater that movie completely breaks
your standard mold of a traditional storytelling
you know with three act structure it's it's a
day in the life of austin texas where we meet
all types of people in all walks of life and
they kind of have intersecting lives each story
kind of crosses over into the next and it's
beautiful and absolutely sweet and inspiring
that would be in my top 10 list another
film would be 2001 a space odyssey directed
by stanley kubrick is probably for me a
perfect film in the sense that I saw it
when I was five years old as a kid and it blew
my mind and I probably watch it every few weeks
and by that I mean I keep it on in the background
while I'm working on on other things but 2001 a
space odyssey is so inspiring is so beautiful and
then I mean it's it's a it's a true work of art
and we don't see a lot of films that live up to
you know the words true work of art these days
and I tend to notice something
new about it every time I see it
there's something fascinating about that film
and and just the artistry the the cinematography
the the way the way that these special effects
in that film stand up to today there was never
a special edition of of 2001 a space odyssey
although pro tip if you if you get the film
on itunes they will allow you to watch the
film with the original 1968 theatrical sound
mix which I strongly recommend but that film
inspires me it it it just it it I kind of turn
inward whenever I watch that film and think about
life and death and the cosmos and the unknown
and all the unanswerable questions that
we you know that religion attempts to to answer
for us that are truly unanswerable only perhaps
by faith and that that film asks those questions
without providing an answer which I think is
terrifying so I love that movie
the original Star Wars also has to be on that
list along with the empire strikes back because
at the time that they were made when
you go back to filmmaking in the 1970s
those movies were dark another favorite I would
add to the list see I'm actually going to get
to the list is taxi driver by martin scorsese
and when you look at the films that were being
made at the time in the 1970s they were very dark
the themes were you know this is a post-nixon era
when you know really it was
it was it was in in the shadow
of all the you know cultural cultural upheaval of
the 1960s and the 70s were the hangover from that
and still films were very dark even in the realm
of you know science fiction and George Lucas set
out to to kind of flip that and say I'm gonna
make a fairy tale for kids because there are no
heroes in movies today I mean at least that's what
he thought in the early 70s when he first began
his journey of writing the original Star Wars
film so that one just stands out and when I say
the original Star Wars the original cut that was
theatrical theatrically released on may 25th 1977
which I saw in a theater just a few days
later that original cut is just remarkable
and famously George Lucas did continue to cut
even after it was only released on about what
a dozen screens initially and the empire strikes
back just sort of flipped that interestingly when
George Lucas set about working on the story for
the empire strikes back and determined that his
heavy which was considered to be you know in
the initial writing of Star Wars a small role
darth vader he considered I'm going to make this
the main hero's father and present a dilemma
that is you know in order to you know defeat
the evil empire I have to kill my own father
and he actually consulted a child psychologist to
learn how this might affect children how the idea
of this might affect children you know we live
in a time now where pop culture is consumed so
quickly that a new disney plus series episode will
come out on a wednesday and we've dissected every
part of it found every easter egg and discussed
it to death within 24 hours of its airing
and the same goes with the film it opens
on a thursday night friday and by monday
it's it's all been it's all been discussed at the
time that that films opened when I was a kid and
seeing movies it was a discussion that lasted for
for some of these films years logan's run I would
add to that list only as a I don't really have a
guilty pleasure I'm just going to say logan's run
because I like the ideas espoused in that film
yes it's shot in a shopping mall in dallas
with futuristic escalators and cheesy special
effects that do not hold up but the performance by
michael york and jenny agather is just transcends
the poor special effects also an amazing score but
that film had a profound effect on me as a kid
and and I just love the ideas that were you know
there's there's a little bit of brave new world
in that in logan's run kind of borrows from that
and the theatrical version of that movie with
michael york is very different than the novel by
william f nolan which I read as a third grader and
it really scarred me because it's such a different
the book and the movie are so vastly different
you know I a top ten list for me is just like
so difficult to put together I can talk about
favorite films and those kind of change with
change with you know what my current thinking is
about things so this is an impossible question
which is what I'm happy you're
asking it's really impossible for me
for me to to respond to that with a top ten but
but these are some of my favorites and and the
reasons they and they they resonate for me to
today now if boyhood had come out when you were
a child do you think that would replace slacker
is there something nostalgic about some of it like
because you know for me I love boyhood
it's not that I didn't like slacker but
I thought boyhood was a masterpiece
so do you think you would have
that would have been your your one of
your top ten yeah that's interesting point
I do think that many of the films from that
are in my top list or movies that I saw at
a younger age they because they left such
a profound impression you know films like
apocalypse now I think and and I would also
say I would add to that list uh pink flamingos
john waters I saw that film when I was 16 years
old I I got a car not because I cared about
girls I got a car because I wanted to go to movies
so when I went to this rep this repertory theater
did a john waters tribute and I saw pink flamingos
and it was shocking to me I couldn't believe
that people that that you know structurally
speaking I mean yeah I guess it follows 3x
structure structure but there's so many shocking
elements in that film you know in addition to
you know glenn milstead the the drag queen divine
who is you know probably one of the greatest drag
queens in cinematic history if that could be said
but that movie had a huge effect on me when I was
16 and then I just like sort of went down a rabbit
hole I was fortunate enough to work at a video
store that had some of his other films I female
trouble might be a personal favorite because it's
it involves christmas day and cha-cha heels which
I thought was so weird I mean john waters kind of
opened my world up to like movies don't have to
be this way they don't have to be Hollywood films
so I would say everything from like
slacker being this small indie movie
made by this kid richard linklater in austin texas
you know that you know just huge effect on me to
like john waters who's been a true independent his
entire career too truthfully George Lucas is an
independent filmmaker you know I mean yes he found
funding in Hollywood but his company lucasfilm was
not located in los angeles he relocated to marin
county in northern california specifically to
get away from Hollywood I don't blame him but
I would say that if there's if there's a thread
that all the films that had an effect on me is
they're all by very independent-minded voices
and my fear with modern Hollywood as it becomes
more corporatized is that those voices will be
lost and the ability to express oneself in
through cinema because it's so expensive
that those voices will be lost and and that's
what I have a real concern with and and
and I see where the 70s filmmaking in Hollywood
was very independently driven with this young
group of filmmakers everyone from spielberg to you
know lucas and scorsese and coppola among others
young at the time they were these new mavericks
in Hollywood and truly had independent voices
I don't know if we'll see an era like that
again and it's it's disheartening to me and
and I hope that there is some push to support
these independent filmmakers I do whatever I
can with my my own outlet film threat you know
we champion these small filmmakers but they just
don't get the support from the mass media like
whatever the latest disney marvel pixar Star Wars
thing is which tends to consume all of the
consume the conversation of film for that week
and so that's kind of been my kind of my life's
work through film thread is just to elevate these
smaller movies I just wonder if we'll see that
same era again if you were the head of a movie
studio what five movies would you green light
right now well if I was head of a movie studio
and I could green light five movies
I don't know if this is cheating
but I would green light three movies which
would be to redo the sequel trilogy to Star Wars
I mean maybe that could count as one but
I feel it was such a dissatisfying end to
I guess what was intended to be a nine film
saga although who knows when you're watching
this maybe they'll do 12 films there'll be
another Star Wars trilogy but I I would I
would green like that because that's a safe bet
and we would we would do it right this time um
the other thing I would do is probably
probably confederacy of dunces I think is a is
a classic book that you know a a lot of people
have you know there have been false starts to
getting that made that book turned into a movie
another one would be the chuck palahniuk
book survivor which is a probably you know
you know one of his greatest books has such
an incredible scene set during the super bowl
that if it's ever committed a film will be
incredible I don't really know how you could
really make survey survivor would have to be done
almost in the way of fight club you know just
like with a big budget and just like not care what
people think but it's it's about a guy telling his
story into the flight recorder of a plane where
he's allowed he's he's taken his plane hostage
he's this spiritual guru who has had been in
trouble with the law who now has commandeered
a plane you know and gotten everyone off the plane
so he is literally telling his life story into the
flight recorder and it's what he's saying into
the flight recorder that's the story being told
brilliant it's it's a book that I
will read every couple years just to
just to remind myself that this is what can happen
in in writing it's amazing so I would I would
green like chuck green light chuck palanik's
survivor which is famously where the the the
phrase suicide girls came from that that name
is you know the website was
named after a line in that book
is it that those type with sort of a gossip yeah
it's sort of like oh those suicide girls and the
founders of the suicide girls website took you
know that line that inspired like oh we're gonna
start a website based on that so that would be
one that I would do I you know I 'd like to see
I don't know that a studio needs to do this I
would like to see a documentary about marcia
lucas marsha lucas had such a profound impact on
on filmmaking in the 70s you know she was just
respected by everyone from Francis Ford Coppola
to martin scorsese to her husband George Lucas
there would not be a George Lucas if not for
marsha lucas there's never been a deep dive
I believe documentary about her speaking today
about you know I you can almost see there's like
Hollywood before marsha lucas and after marsha
lucas the impact that she had there's a there's a
rare and I've never seen it but I've read articles
about a rare rough cut of the first assembly of
Star Wars black and white you know taken from
you know the dailies they cut it together and
it's just like and it's an unwatchable film it's
terrible the original Star Wars I mean there's
like inappropriate humor which kind of reared its
head again in episode one the phantom menace but
you can see the the choices that marcia cut things
out there are things where just a few frames are
cut and it changes the dynamic of a character
as seen in the cantina bar at most at most icely
before you know luke skywalker and obi-wan
kenobi meet with han solo and chewbacca han
solo's sitting with this attractive woman
and just sitting with her and she gets up
and walks away marcia lucas cut some frames
she's not there she's not even in the movie
she saved that film in the editing many of the
special effects in the original Star Wars the
reason they're so impactful is because they're
not on screen for very long so at the time that
that came out I mean it was it was so fast-paced
and a lot of the effects objectively didn't work
but because they were on screen for so brief a
moment it worked so i'd love to see a documentary
about marsha lucas that really really details
her contribution to film not just Star Wars but
you know how she was so widely re respected you
know by all the greatest directors of the 70s
you know and then after her parting ways with
george you know she was basically ostracized
I mean she was you know working with her was
she was just out of Hollywood at that point
so that one is a huge shame
i'm trying to think of others there's just
so many I would like to see the
comic book the dark knight returns by
frank miller that four issue series you know
Zack Snyder was inspired by that when he made
batman v superman I the thing that made the
dark knight returns so compelling was that it
it had all this history in it it would be great to
see that comic book turned and turned into a film
another one and maybe someone from
marvel is is if someone from marvel
watches this or listening listens to this
this is a comic book that no one knows about
I bring up every once in a while it's a comic book
called strikeforce muratori and it's about a group
of people that have superpowers they that it's in
a far future of of the world where aliens invade
and they're slaughtering humans and the humans
are losing so there's a program that's developed
to give people superpowers there's only one catch
you only live for about a year so you don't know
what kind of superpower you're gonna get you don't
know how you're gonna help in this battle against
these alien these invading aliens but
you only get to live for a year so you're
you're putting your life on the line and sometimes
you don't even live that long so it focuses on the
second group of heroes that have gone through this
process it's it's a series that that marvel did
back in the 80s never forgot that story that it
was really impactful filled with pathos and drama
a whole group of I mean it was you know it
just a whole diverse group of characters
all this like the the world's at stake but it
wouldn't really fit into the marvel universe
at all it's you know because it's just sort of
the separate universe but i'd love to see that
I guess if I'm a Hollywood executive I'm green
lighting big budget you know franchise films
so maybe the marsha lucas documentary wouldn't
necessarily fit into that all that well
but you know god there's just so many I 'd
love to see love to see made what would you
cancel well I would have cancelled probably
maybe the last five years of franchise reboots
there has almost universally not been one
that's succeeded in a way where everyone
is like that was awesome I mean you know just a
quick example like for example lord of the rings
the lord of the rings trilogy not
the hobbit the lord of the rings
we don't really talk about that that series
of movies so much the reason is there's no
debate there's no debate people who don't like
lord of the rings I'm not a fantasy film fan
right and I wasn't a lord of the rings fan
necessarily I remember the hobbit cartoon
by rankin bass back in the day which used wrote an
early form of rotoscoping which is interesting but
but I was not a fan of lord of the rings per se
and that movie made me that series of movies made
me a fan you know it's incredible we don't really
debate about that because there's not that much
debate they're objectively amazing films if you're
a hardcore tolkien fan yes there are nitpicks but
there's almost no debate about it but I don't know
that we'll ever stop debating the disappointment
that that was that Star Wars sequel trilogy I
feel like that is a debate that will just continue
I just wonder will Hollywood learn the lessons I
would want to go back in almost every franchise
that was rebooted ghostbusters terminator
dark fate you know there's so many you know
did we need more Fast and the Furious movies you
know I I don't know it it seems to me that these
that these franchise reboots I mean in some
cases there has too much time has elapsed
between you know they want to do another film and
and whatnot it's just because the branding exists
right there's that recognition you know like when
they you know like when they name a movie after a
familiar song right like that's sort of a laziness
on the part of on the part of Hollywood but yeah I
would if I could cancel or wipe away or if I could
just do the snap that thanos did I would get rid
of every franchise reboot post probably 92. what
about a star is born did you see the first one
yeah a star is born well that see but it's
such a different approach because there's
you know it's the music world has changed
it's about being invested in those characters
that I don't really think fits in that category
I think that star is born is just a classic story
that's just like okay it's this is familiar the
bottles from familiar we're gonna put like maybe a
slight different flavor you know I like those they
have those different flavors of coke like vanilla
cherry cherry vanilla orange coke lime coke they
do make that so it's familiar but with like a a
twist and yeah I mean that that stars-born
movie with bradley cooper and lady gaga is
pretty damn incredible you know I really
don't have much to say about that one
you know except good job bradley cooper as the
head of a movie studio what would be your mission
and what would it be called by the way what would
your studio oh well yes it would be called gore
film okay that would be my movie studio and I
would I mean look you have to tell stories where
it's an amazing story without the superficial
elements right there has to be something to say
about you know our current climate we live in
such divided times I don't know why there are
so few films about that why are we so divided why
is it that people living in the same country who
all want the same things what are what why are
we so divided now and there are so few films that
are dedicated to that you know I do see a lot of
documentaries and generally the documentary films
of a political nature are generally
they're on the left or they're on the right
and it's it's really disappointing because as
the viewer I would like to be able to come to
my own conclusion rather to be led into one that
you determined before you started making the movie
so I'm surprised that when you look at the kind
of issues that films from the 70s you know were
were taking on very challenging issues I don't
know why we're not doing that now so much of
Hollywood now is about dictating some sort of
predetermined message it's not entertaining
I don't mind if some of that is is woven
in but I do mind being told how to think
and I think it that if if I was head of
a studio i'd not be telling my audience
how to think and I would certainly be listening
to what the audience wants and maybe giving them
something they didn't expect that I hope they
really like but certainly not pounding them over
the head with some sort of agenda you know I think
I think we're more alike than we are different
and I don't know why we're not reminded of that
so that would that would be my mission and to tell
original stories giving opportunity to small
indie filmmakers to tell original stories
taking some risks not every science fiction
movie needs to have over-the-top spectacle
with the fate of the universe at stake when you
look back at some of the old star trek episodes
there's so few special effects shots right it's
star trek really delved into the realm of ideas
and i'd like to see science fiction come
back to dealing in the realm of big ideas
and you don't always need big spectacle or big
budgets to tell those stories so do you think
Hollywood can learn lessons from let's say art
house cinema or foreign films where there's a
subtlety there may still be a message but it's
it's letting it breathe it's letting the viewer
discover it whether they're going to agree with
it or not whereas maybe in western culture we're
beating them over the head it's so overt that
there's no hiding it that it's forced I 'm just
curious what yeah I think I think we've forgotten
you know joseph campbell and the hero's journey
you know I you know I guess so much of films today
seem like they kind of want to break that mold
there's a reason that mold works it's kind
of embedded in human dna you know that kind
of around the fire storytelling is is universal
and that seems to seems to have been forgotten
lately in trying to break that mold I'm just
I'm just you know especially when we see you
know the hero's journey for so many female lead
characters I think a disservice is being done
to people who look up to those characters because
it's made to look easy people forget how much
failure there has been in some of the iconic
movie characters everyone from luke skywalker to
Rocky people forget in the original Rocky film
Rocky loses he loses the fight now he gains
respect which is more of what that film is about
but he lost the fight in the original raiders of
the lost ark indiana jones loses he's tied up
his only logic is I'm going to close my eyes to
not to not get caught up in these evil spirits
that are coming out to murder everything right
he kind of loses I mean maybe he wins in the end
because he gets he gets the ark he doesn't really
get the ark because it's tucked away in a giant
warehouse but he loses there's something about
losing and this happens more in indie
films than it does in Hollywood movies
you know what happened in the empire strikes
back luke lost he lost the fight he lost his hand
you have to I really feel like if it's not
tied to character I don't know how the events
of that film really can be meaningful
if it's not tied to some hero character
journey that you're on where you can because we
all fail in life believe me we all fail in life
life is just I mean look it's just learning
from your failures right I mean that's
and I've made plenty of mistakes in my personal
and professional life that I've paid for and I
like to think I'm who I am today is better that's
that's just failures failure is how we learn and I
feel like by not imbuing that lesson we're
doing a disservice to young moviegoers who
might look up to these heroes it really is
it's kind of a disappointing time to see how
franchises are being you know twisted in a
way that I don't think serves the audience but
but there's something to be said for losing
characters that lose more often than they win and
what exactly you win I think Rocky
probably being the most obvious or
best example of that because then they just
made Rocky too Sylvester Stallone made Rocky too
and the old it's pretty much the same movie I
mean there's some little fun differences in it but
but it's the same movie but he wins
in that one he actually wins the fight
but it's kind of the same movie
they just revisit a lot of the same
stuff in the film but but he wins whatever but
the fact that Rocky lost but he won he had a
girlfriend Adrian he wanted girlfriend even though
he's kind of his simpleton right this sort of thug
but anyone respect it wasn't about winning
that fight it was about winning respect
and that was tied to him in his humanity and
his soul and his character and being that's why
they made so many Rocky movies because that
character's so endearing you know and and we're
on that journey that constant constant failure
until the end and then he wins the fight but
but in the first one he lost and and almost no one
remembers that if you ask right now ask any person
you see like who won the fight in the first Rocky
and it was a Rocky won the fight no he didn’t.